قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تستكمل انسحابها
من منطقه الشيخ رضوان محدثه دمارا هائلا
في ممتلكات المواطنين ومنازلهم كما
تشاهدون الان هذا الدمار هذا الدمار على
مد
البصر هذا هو الشارع الثاني قد تغيرت
معالمه بالكامل لا يوجد منزل لم تطاله
نيران القوات الاسرائيليه عدا عن الدمار
الواسع الذي ينتشر في كل الارجاء هذه
المنطقه منطقه منكوبه نكبتها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كما نكبت باقي
المناطق في شمال قطاع غزه وفي قطاع
غزه هذا بيتي قاعدين فيه انا وعمي واولاد
ابني و ومرا ابني قاعدين فيه وولعوا النار
فينا واحنا نا
جوا يعني طلعنا من هنا باعجوبه ما بعرفش
ايش اللي صار يعني شردنا بعجوه وطخ فوق
رؤسنا طخ علينا جوا الدار بعجوه وحرقوا
الدار فينا وعجوه طلع من الدار نطينا على
الدار الجنده برضه ضلوا نطخه على الدور
هنا وحرقوا الدور زي ما انت شايف هذا هو
مربع التقوى كما تشاهدون خوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي دمرت هذا المربع بالكامل لم
تبقي منزلا واحدا في هذا المربع عدا عن ان
المسجد انتهت معالمه ولا احد ولا احد يعرف
اين هذا اين هذا المسجد الضخم وهو اكبر
مساجد هذا الحي ايضا المدارس المجاوره
مربع المدارس تم تدميره كما تشاهدون وحرق
جميع الفصول في هذه الم التي كانت تؤوي
الاف النازحين لم يبقى فصلا واحدا يعمل
دمر الجامع مدارس لا بدهم ايانا نتعلم ولا
بدهم ايانا نصلي ولا بدهم لاطفالنا اي
حياه عدمو الحياه الحمد لله رب العالمين
هذه مدرسه الدحيان كما تشاهدون قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ارتكبت بها حرائق
واسعه ودمارا هائلا وكونها تنتقم من هذه
النقطه التي انقذت حياه الالاف من الجرحى
يعني هذه كانت النقطه حده بتعمل في منطقه
شمال
غزه نا لا ايام بدون اكل الحمد لله واطفال
وحليب ما فيش ولا في اي
حاجه جت في الشوارع والله العظيم ث ايام
ما شربنا ولا اكلنا ايام واحنا مصرين انا
وابن قلب الد لا مي ولا اكل ولا اي مؤسسه
لحياه هنا انتشال جثامين الشهداء كما
تشاهدون بعد ان خرجت قوات التلال
الاسرائيلي من هذا الحي حيث جهزوا لهم
مقبره هنا في هذا
الملعب جمعه يعني صار لهم ثمان ايام مرمين
في الشارع ما قدرناش نصهم لانه القصف كان
موجود في المنطقه وبشكل عنيف مش طبيعي
واحنن اضطرينا نطلع من المنطقه لانهم
حذرونا باكثر من سلك من غاز وسكناهم في
الشارع اليوم تمكنا بعد تراجع اليهود
تمكننا نجيبه
منن طبعا الحمد لله على كل حال انا بوجه
رساله
للامم المتحده بوجه رساله للصيب الاحمر
للهلال الاحمر لحقوق الانسان لكل الدنيا
ان تيجي تنظر بعين الرحمه لاطفال وشيوخ
ونساء قطاع غزه المكلومه الجنود
جنود معظم المستوطنين حاقدين
حاقدين ضربوا اطفال صفوا ناس حرقوا بيوت
حرقوا سيارات الحمد لله البيت والسيارات
مش مهم المهم المهم الانسان نقول للمقاومه
الله يحفظكم الله يحفظكم غصب عن
الجميع المقاومه واحنا معها انا بيتي انهد
ودار انهدت واولادي استشهدوا ومع المقاومه
الحمد لله رب العالمين انا رسالتي بنا
بسلم امري الى
الله وحسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل